pato impostore da solo mi farò una
killah al secondo madonna che qua
vogliono tutti che in un casinò guarda
ammazzare qualcuno subito subito ciò che
c'è sete dvd vivi dic il satam va bene
nessuno ancora riporta che un apposita
di quella allucinante ancora di suonare
portavo iniziamo abbastanza set nel
senso basta che ricorda che ogni cosa
nobody e rock che mi prendono almeno mi
aiuto aiuto non c'è nessuno che passa di
là due ore è uno bucci cio che noi a 6
ore fa nessuno le può allora ora farà
mario una morta davanti unica per sorsi
che abbiamo una cosa in primis
vessicchio pulitissimo perché abbiamo
agito le tasche visibili e affatto le
foglie ei ma non sapevo vestito pulito
chi ha chiesto che io mac chi è che può
avere il coraggio di uccidere martina
matteo roba è una roba se posso perché
mi sa che tutto vede robe buddy che mi
sposto perché avevo una paura
incredibile but it's a seguirvi però
avrebbe potuto veramente uscire milan
dove però però non lo so perché magari
c'è la roba quindi non lo ha fatto
non lo so manama per ora non ci sto più
seguendo poi sono andato in elettrica
per le tasche
ok che non ci sono mai stato con voi
come noi quando io quadro e corridoio
tipo 20 secondi fa interessante questa
radio skipper era garante siamo con un
impostore quindi massima poi morta
martina
secondo me i ragazzi si può provare a
fare un'altra un'altra bella rush contro
va di forza sto punto perché baldi è
l'unico che aveva il mio alibi se lo
ammazzo io
secondo me non cambia niente la prima
fase 1 statham
vediamo di saltare il tombino come una
tartaruga ninja la casa è bassa ma di
dover sempre il fermo aurea my boys sono
passato del corridoio leadership c'era
bhatti che guardava le luci degli osci
lombardi fermo esatto eravate tutti tipo
marci e robbie pare fermi e io vado giù
è vedova di fermo mica go e torno sopra
e vetro fede perché valgono i bar le
partite che si chiude scende esattamente
dove stava di poca spesa
no no no no io posso andato oltre a un
lasciano vivere ma di guardare le
abbiamo scelto quello che ho visto e poi
sono passato in storage dove me pare che
ho incontrato mar ci diamo a metà siamo
una città asciugamani noi diretto e red
rob
allora è un casino perché sono una donna
ragazzi la sola veramente un disastro 22
ore
ma se me raggio kikkio 6 messaggio
kikkio si può anche pensare ma la vedo
che rob è andato là quindi in elettrica
faccio questo tra ok adesso faccio mai
appena passa qualcuno ha già tanto
ok e dovevo andare più veloci secondo me
sai che doveva andare più veloce perché
si sa che il vostro sousse non era al
imposto a matteo male vero non so no
matter stava con me ora ero
completamente cieco non ho visto niente
perché ero sopra in cafeteros uscita
arrivare neanche davanti
basta non ho visto nulla dopo questa
famiglia e tutto su sul bot
e cosa devo dirti che vedevo quando lo
vedevo grazie matteo bravo impostore può
uccidere matteo per favore grazie ai a
ok lasciate marcire marcelo perdendo
tuoi effettivamente occupati fare finta
di aver finito le tasche sperando che
non siano tutti appiccicati potrei anche
fare questa mostra quello che passano
molto vicini loro nessuno è andato a
fare le luci e lui ci sono ancora giungo
ammazzato marci allora adesso se riesco
a far votare vessicchio è un bene se del
capo a ruotare vessichio un bene ok dio
o sono aggregato all'unico gruppo che
avevo e io persona voi foste 6 formò in
realtà vi stavate seguendo per uccidervi
occhiata l'ho fatto una ragazza verrà
aggregato anche dove siamo 6 stradino e
noi nota vista di seguendo per uccidere
la sono subito con la morte perché si
schieri da solo e questo mi preoccupa
troppo dato unico perché era uno fra
loro te lo posso assicurare io ho sempre
seguito peraltro sempre seguito matteo
mentre noi ci sia nessuno ma chi avete
votato schifo io chiesi skipass chi poi
gursky parole chiave silvio
raga io perché l'avevo ancora aperto
e allora voi non lo so ragazzi 16 15 14
elmo faccio sabotaggio reattore da
ragazzo ora di andare in realtà il sogno
è stata veramente una partita molto
fanny and my boys impostore ma dai
ragazzi dai facciamo un impostore
no ma giocatela mattino già tante non
c'è tanto di cori per problema in realtà
tutti avevamo c'è chi è che manca march
massimo la catola morite ok io posso
farmi male si chiama quando saranno anzi
lo capiremo se io ce li ho io ce l'ho e
mi dovrà fare da altri ma tranquille my
boys sono belle kyrie sei ridicolo hai
capito
ma il boys sperare mafiosa quando dicevo
per scherzo veramente va bè ragazzi the
last imposto in the world is the good fa
vj vediamo se riusciamo a fare una bella
partita
possiamo anche mettere subito elettrica
alla mamma ma alla fine ha fatto ciò
dico da 10 sono tutti fermi qua aiuto
ragazzi agiscono con una scimmia che
john ha voglia di far fuori la gente che
emilia della vispa polo tutta la faccia
per terra aspetta un attimo che emergono
niente poi in emergenza che non fai
niente noi abbiamo marzo ok allora
niente chiudo cosa è che noia si uccisa
ma tu sei con me però penso che siano
più felici sicuro si è arrestata da
miglior play del mondo
[Musica]